hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to go simulator there
was just too much content to cover in
just one episode so let's find out what
other crazy things have been added since
the update first of all I have to pick
up my date pani I can't go anywhere
without her
Bonnie come along thank you baby you're
the best you and I are gonna go have so
much fun if you know what I mean maybe
Oh Bonnie come on you oh god not again
bonnie bonnie your neck doesn't look too
good there how are you doing how you
feeling I like the subtle shake with no
animation it's just delightful okay I'm
glad they got the water physics down
because there's oh okay
well it makes a lot of sense you just do
what you do I'm gonna go over this way
can I go in there hang on wait nope
come on cooperate was like get in oh
hello
Oh repulsive power gain what does that
even mean
whoa is that my repulsive power I don't
even know what happened bonk hello
anything oh hi are you Ninja Turtles
they look oddly like Shrek say I ever
met you bastards
okay Michael Bay turtle sorry
Oh God well why is everything in this
game so terrified Jesus kill everybody
don't even think about it I'm a wild
turtle you are executor Shrek there's no
oh god I'm sorry I'll just leave your
home now bye everybody
bye Michael baked Turtles now everybody
oh you look cold you want me to help you
there thank you goodbye
you're welcome thank you thank you
you're welcome you're welcome thank you
you're welcome goodbye dorable think
I've ever seen I'm not oh oh that is
much better
hello Bonnie goodbye Barney oh no fell
oh my god this is the cutest thing I've
ever seen in my entire life hello I want
to be your friend I am a classy goat
I'm the classiest you'll ever see
how are you doing today you look lovely
you taste lovely thank you are you sorry
well what is my spit repel you now are
you very antagonize but seriously you
don't have to have this adverse Roque
I'm adorable you are intolerant would
like to give this classy penguin a ride
anybody I knew you would Bonnie what
turn up Barney
what the hell happened where Barney go I
really would sir sir sir
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be upfront with
you guy you're not Bonnie I don't know
what you did with Bonnie I don't know
how you changed out with Bonnie
boy you ain't body goodbye yeah goodbye
goodbye forever
you're coming Oh God not you do are you
gonna keep breaking are you gonna break
more oh I'm so cute okay not that type
it we don't know I'm sliding uphill but
I'm not gonna question things at this
point okay weird tall slender goat my
cuteness is gonna repel your evil hey-oh
I did what where to go where you go what
are you doing there you go who got here
there excuse me
yeah that's right yeah yeah well now how
you gonna come with me now you're coming
with me dude a sir have a go to deliver
I don't know what to do with them
take him over here and drop in in the
sea whoo come with me to all God your
head um friend Oh your head doesn't seem
to be doing so good okay where'd you go
buddy are you going okay you're gonna be
my friend of Destruction huh you gonna
help me take over the world eh you're my
new best pal you and I are gonna team up
forever and ever
I like your fruit there man oh sorry
he's just uncontrollable
oh my god somehow that's even more
adorable come on
no no no okay
all right okay I got it I got it yeah
woohoo the but we're gonna but we're
gonna bot we got about how do I turn how
do I turn how do I turn how do I turn
why do I do a turn oh God
back it up back it up forward it up good
good hey are you doing there buddy
still doin okay oh you have fun over
there okay hey sir I'd like to partake
from outside with Lu Lu yet I never seen
a whale before they are you with you
Ignace self her friend I see you there
how are you doing oh that good just eat
your chest oh thank you thank you sir
thank you for pushing me that is exactly
what I needed you are a good friend
thank you and what a tight buttocks you
have I'd slap it if I could get my fin
over there thank you thank you sir have
a good day now
oh god where am I going
this is normal okay Oh God
oh this is a mistake I'm a beautiful
ballerina do you like my simple elegance
[Music]
okay Scooby a goddamn second here still
got it oh this wasn't meant for mortal
men Oh God
stop it so big so Derby whoo that is a
disgusting thing Jesus I love my little
horns over on the side there but good
god that's terrifying
her work you're ready to be horked oh
god I'm a whale torpedo oh my god this
is amazing
okay boys and girls I'll be your guide
I've got my nose right now but I feel
very bad for you huh oh well goddamn
aren't you just the most terrifying
thing I've ever seen in my entire life
Hey look everybody its jake mi Jake's a
dog I mean Jake the goat and I'm super
fast somehow this is like 10 times it's
disturbing a second other coat that I've
ever been hey don't you look at me don't
you look back when I'm running okay you
just take your wibbly-wobbly but no do
not look at me you're like oh god Jake
you're so disturbing Hey hello someone
over there something over there why
isn't anything happening huh
hello oh you're on fire oh that's why
you're upset I would be too if I was on
fire but it looks like Jake is actually
impervious to fire see okay no Jake is
not you all spread the love and by love
I mean fire and death hello come on okay
I see oh this is gonna be so this is I
beg I can't even try to do as Lloyd Berg
impression so don't even ask it serves
this is Roy Berg bored bored want food
and money and companionship can also
hide bargain goddamn boards go did I eat
you I hate you too didn't ah my friend
hello oh ma
oh god you're just ten times as scary
don't even try to kick me Zoidberg been
kicked many times before this other view
you could do it would change that I'm
not a goat I think it's anybody anybody
please please Zoidberg
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen last but not least
my personal favorite new goat of the new
update a friggin shopping cart I'm not
even joking not even lying this is not a
mod this is not something from the
workshop this is literally an unlockable
goat in this game please don't mind me
don't mind the we're talking shopping
Kurt someone should give this some magic
of rahat you would love to do a prank
oh yes please fall in my presence and
then be stomped on by that dude pardon
excuse me sir very important shopping
cart coming true it's gotta make it over
the threshold
how about Al me nobody assists the
shopping cart plus a ride me wants to
ride me ok looks like I'm stuck here for
a while so I won't be doing anything
more with my amazing shopping cart goat
but either way I think I covered just
about everything in the new update if I
miss something
please let me know in the comments below
but I think this will be the last go
simulator video for a while until the
next update comes to the game so either
way thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done especially the funny play
games Leslie with especially the funny
game guy especially the awesome games
playlist where I've got a whole bunch of
cool games that I played in the past
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]